あの論理ですか まあ直感ですかというテーマでございまして
まあ大変暑いところで
論理のところじゃないと思いますけど
私の頭もその状態になって
なんか焼いてる状態で
で 皆様もなかなかその論理的なことを考えるところじゃないかもしれませんだけど
まあとにかくですから
できるだけ簡単に いくらか仏教的な話をさせていただきます
うん あの  このテキストに書いてあるように
このまあ西洋的なこの脳の研究をする場合はね
まあ右の方はまあ感情的な芸術的なところとか
左の方はまあ数学やらね
論理的なことをやってるんだというふうなまあ話はあります
えーまああまり脳の研究っていうのはね
それほどやってはないんですが
あの できないんですよ
でもそれなりにいろいろまあ
脳の機能にまあ研究して
まあ体の働きにも脳の中にちゃんと地図がありまして
その一部一部仕事を分けてもらって
手の動き 顔の動き 足の動き
まあそういうものを一部一部管理していると
で 言語はまたある一部で管理してやったりして
で またいろんなものを記憶する部分があったりとか
まあそういうふうに部分に分けても
まだまだ脳のこと 脳のことはまあわからないですね
で 一番このわからないところは
まあ人間はまあ考えることなんですよ
だからあの コンピューターなどいろいろ機械作ったりするんだけど
まあそういうものには
この新しく物事を考えることはできないんですね
で 人間の脳の不思議なところは
そのもう考えるという機能なんですね
考えたり 判断したりする
だからそれも科学者は何か客観的な研究で何か発見できないでしょうかというふうなところでは頑張っていると思いますけどね
なぜかというと ものを考えるロボットでも作ればいいんじゃないかなと
そうすると何でもプログラム組まなくてもいいんではないか
楽ではないかと で まあそこはまああの映画の世界で
まあ余計に考えて ロボットに支配されている世界とか
もう人間をもう馬鹿にされちゃって
もう人間を奴隷にしてしまって
ロボットたちが世界支配するようになるんじゃないかなとか
そういうふうに SF的なね
まあ物語までは作ってはいるんです
だから考えればこれ怖いんですよ
例えばロボットを一つ作ったところで
そのロボットに自分のことは自分でできるようになってしまっちゃえば
そのロボットは次のロボットを作るでしょうに
それは自分の好きなように作ったりするんだから
もう人間には何もできなくなっちゃうんですね
まあそれは可能性あり得るかないかっていうことはわかりませんだけど
で 今までやっぱりできなかった
できないところは この考える機能なんですね
機械でできないことは
数学的な答えを出すのは機械的だから
コンピューターの方がはるかに早くやってくれるんです
でも それについて何か考えようとしちゃうと
それはコンピューターにはできないんですね
脳の働きっていうのはまあそれぐらいのことで
お釈迦様の教えとこれとどんな関係ありますかと
まあ我々はもうこちらでお釈迦様の直接的な教えを紹介する場だから
あんまりこの西洋的な思想は言っちゃうとちょっと外れてしまうんです
でお釈迦様の仏教という教えと
この論理と何か関係ありますかと
でお釈迦様の教えは皆様ももう結構お読みになっていらっしゃるでしょうし
この原始経典に翻訳ございますし
だいたいこの仏教に興味ない方々でも
初めて読んでも ああ なんとかわかるんだと
まあ理解できるんだと
初期経典だったら 後の経典が
例えば大乗経典なんかは
そんな簡単に理解できる論理的なものではありません
例えば般若心経がございまして
色は空であると 空は色であると
という何なのかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
で それもよくわかったようなふりをしている方々いるんだけど
まあそれはもう大乗経典で
でもお釈迦様がおっしゃっているものは
この中村元先生なんかね
日本訳されているし 増田善美先生とかね
で 最近この片山一郎先生も訳しているし
で そういう真理の言葉とかね
で 神々との対話とかね
悪魔との対話とか そういう小さな小さなね
文庫本で出ているでしょうに
で そういうものをお読みになると
あれ これさっぱりわからないということはないと思います
大体読んだらわかるんですよ
理解できるんですね お釈迦様の直接的な教えっていうのは
まあどんな例を出せばいいかな
大体どんな経典でも お釈迦様の教えだったら
読んだら人間にはわかるんですね
理解できるんですね でもそれと般若心経を比べてみると
何なのかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
色は空であると 色って何なのかと説明していない
空ってどういうものかと説明していない
それで空は色であると書いてあるでしょうに
空すなわち色であると
空即是色と そうするとみんな当たり前ではないかと思っちゃうんですね
色イコール空であるならば
空イコール色ですよと
でも私はそれで人間の頭を騙されていると
本当のことを言っていないと
私はすごくいい加減なことを言ってますけどね
で 私の出す例は 人間みんな死すべきものですよと
故に死すべきものはみんな人間ですよと
と言えますかと で それは間違うでしょうに
ですから 色は空であるというのはいいんですが
空は色であると言っちゃうと
まあ屁理屈じゃないかと
それはもう正真正銘の間違いなんですよ
だから論理的に間違いあるんだけど
もうありがたい教えだから
もうみんなありがたがってもう写経したりするんですけど
まあありがたくはないんですけど
私にとっては で それと
この初期時代のお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
もうどこから見てもまあわかりやすいんですよ
そのわかりやすいってどういうことかというと
論理的なんですね 論理的だからわかるんですよ
で この間 掲載 ニュース出たものなんですけど
このゼロ金利対策でを決めて
なんとか景気回復 景気回復するだろうということで
そういうことに決めてあったんでしょうし
そこでいくら時間経っても一向にゼロ金利対策
景気回復はしません それでまたその偉い方々を集めて
ですから この対策は続けましょうと決めたんだそうです
だから そういうふうな心理は
論理はちょっとわからないんですね
なんでそうするんですかと
あまり効き目がないんだったら
そのままやめた方がいいんじゃないかなと一般的には思いますけど
だから論理的だったらわかりやすい
論理的でないとわかりにくい
ということがあるんです
で それでこのお釈迦様の教えを調べてみて
本当にお釈迦様の教えかないかと知りたければ
論理性があるかないかと見るだけでも十分ですよ
一般的に読んで ああ そうでしょうねとか
ああ なるほどなと思えるような教えだったら
まあ問題ないと思います
なんだこれという感じになるならば
これちょっと違うんじゃないかなとか
そういうふうになるんだったら
まあちょっと考え直した方がいいかもしれませんしね
ですから 人間には物事を理解するためには論理性が必要なんです
それはもう避けられないんです
論理性がなくなっちゃうと
何も理解できなくなるんですね
できなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで 大体我々は物事を理解するときは
覚えておくときでも なんとかの論理構成にして覚えてしまう
いろんな勉強するときでもね
こういうことは覚えておかなくちゃいけないと思ったら
何か頭の中で何か論理構成を作って
それで覚えてしまう ですから
人間の脳細胞っていうのは
やっぱり論理的なものを理解できるようにできているんですよ
ですから 大体この数学みたいなものっていうのは
まあ結構人間にわかりやすい
歴史の勉強するよりも
考古学を勉強するよりも
数学の方がわかりやすいと思いますけどね
でも残念なことに数学嫌いな人々もまあいるんですが
まあそれは別にどこかで自信がなくなったとか
あるいは先生の教え方が間違ったとか
そういうことではないかなと思いますけど
そうでないとあまりにも単純で
まあわかりやすいものだと思いますね
ですから まず人間に 我々には論理的人間っていうのは論理的な動物であることは
まあ一つもう理解しておかないと
それで その論理って何なのかということがまた問題になってきて
まあ論理的なんですけど
世の中で 我々はしっかりした論理は持ってないんですね
論理自体はガタガタになってしまう
そういうこともありまして
あんまり明確にそれは明確に理解しようとしないんですね
だから論理的に真理に至ることはあまりなくなってしまっちゃって
真理でなくなる場合もあります
だから 論理と真理という 2つをつなげて考えないと
論理的に物事を理解して
やっぱり最後には真理を理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
事実を理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことだから 仏教の世界でだいたいかなり昔も倫理
論理学という学問を作ったんですよ
だから 自分の国の仏教学部の場合でも
仏教学部を卒業したければ
仏教倫理学という科目も一つあります
それもちゃんと一年授業を受けなくちゃいけないんです
で 英訳もあって 日本訳もあるかな
ソ連の仏教学者で 昔のね
シュヴァツキという人がブディストロジックというすごい大きな本 2冊書いてるんですよ
で その本 2冊っていうのは昔あった
あるかサンスクリット語で書いた仏教の倫理学の翻訳なんです
すごい明確に分析して
この論理っていうのはどういうものかということをもうすごい厚い本なんですけど
2冊になってます で まだまだあの...本はいくつかもありますけど
昔書かれた本はね ですから
この論理ということが
あの 一応仏教に対しては大変大事なことなんです
大変大事なことなんです
で なぜ大事ですかというと
仏教も一つ 世の中にあるたくさん宗教の中で一つの宗教なんですね
一般的に見れば で もう一つの宗教だからといって
仏教もみんな言ってることは
ただ言葉を変えて言ってるわけじゃないんです
で 例えば神様の名前を変えるとかね
イエホワにするか アブラマズダにするか
ブラフマにするかとかね
まあ各宗教で神様の名前は違うんです
ですから まあそれで名前
誰が名前をつけたんですかとも聞きたくなっちゃうし
名前どうであろうか 神様ですからね
まあそういう風に何か仏教も
まあただ世の中にあるごく普通の宗教で言ってる同じことを言葉を変えて言ってるんでしょうかと
で そこら辺は仏教はまあちょっと違うところがございまして
まずこの仏教の特色っていうのは
この信仰というもの あの
信仰からすべて始まりますよという教えではないんですね
まず信じましょうと それからまああなたに言ってることはわかるんですよと
そういうこの知識の土台は信仰ではありません
そこに仏教 特にお釈迦様はもうかなりそれ壊しちゃうんですね
信仰はダメだったら何がいいんですかと言えば
やっぱり出てくるのは論理なんです
で あの あのインドのね
今もあるあの インドの宗教でいえばね
信仰っていうのはありますけど
このインドではバクティと言うんですが
あの まあ英語で言えば
このフェイス ビリーフという言葉 2つありますけど
ビリーフという言葉がありますね
あのインドでよく使っている言葉っていうのはバクティ
このインドで使うこのバクティという言葉
この あの日本の適切な言葉はあるんだけど
私は今思い出せません
何ですか？日本語で言えばバッティ
ん？信奉 信奉じゃない
信奉 ああ こうとにかくちょっと漢字はどういう漢字？うんうん
で まあそういう信じると奉仕
奉仕 信奉と言いたいんですけど
一応 あの 何といいますかね
とにかく無条件で信じる
もうすごく この あの まあやっぱり恐怖感みたいなものは入ってるんですね
この信じるものに対して恐怖とも言わないんだけど
もうもの徹底的に頭下げて
まあ信じるという意味でバッティなんですけど
まあ英語の faith belief の場合は
まあこのバッティほどあの怖さがないんだけど
すごくもうもうありがたく信頼して信じるというふうな
まあ信頼して信じるっていうような意味なんですね
英語での言葉の場合は
バッティの場合はこの信頼するところじゃないんです
まあどうにもならないんですよ
状態で すごい向こうの方が強いんです
いわゆるいたずら信じると
で あの まあそれはまあ普通に
あの まあ宗教といえば必ずしも出てくる条件なんですね
宗教でいえば まずあの信仰しなくちゃいけないんですね
で いわゆる宗教の世界で
まずまあなんとかなんとかまず言ってくれる
人間に対して 人間はこういうものであると
こういう風にできたものであると
まずいくらかの説明はする
それはもう信じてもらわなきゃ困ると
信じたところで次の説明はわかるんだと
いや あまり例をいろいろ出しちゃうと
ちょっとまあきつい言葉になるんだから
あの まあ例えば人類が神様が作ったとする
まずそれを教えてくれる
あなた方は神様が作りましたよと
それまず信じなさい その項目を
はい わかりました 信じますと言ったところで
ですからこうしなさい
ああしなさいと それでそれからは論理は成り立つんです
だから人間は神様の命令を聞くべきですよと言えばわかるんですよ
なぜならば 神様が私を作ったんだから
私が神様が言うことをするのは当たり前ではないかということに論理が成り立つんですね
だから この そこは仏教の人はすごくややこしいところなんですね
で だから壊しちゃうんですよ
なぜかというと 初め何かあの
何か考え方 知識をいくつかあって
それは無条件で信じる
信じてから次のこと論理的に成り立つと
まあわかりやすいですから
皆さんもよく勉強なさってるんだから
まあキリスト教の例を出しますけど
例えばキリスト教だったら
信仰するべき項目はいくつか決まってるんでしょうし
神様のことやら イエス様のことやら
受難 受難を受けたことやら
それから復活したことやらね
それいくつかの項目ありまして
それはもう信じるしか道がないんですね
それを信じてから あの説法はわかりやすいんです
人間をお互いに優しくしなくちゃいけないんですと言ったら
はい わかりましたと で
なぜですかと聞いたら
もうそれは聞いてはいけません
あれはもうとにかく信じなくてはならないんだから
私は勉強してた時は 私は聞きたい質問がありまして
このキリスト教の学者の方々に
なぜ神様が人間を作ったんですか？と
で それに全然答えが出てこないんですね
だから私に逆に質問されてあったんですね
あなたはまあここまで聖書を勉強して
で でもここまでいろいろ合格もしていて
なぜ神様は信じないんですかと
だから私は逆に質問したのは
なぜ神様が人間を作ったんですか？と
だからそれは人間聞く質問じゃないんだと
そのわけは神のみ知ってるんだと
神しか知りませんと ですから
このやっぱりまず信仰してしまえば
だいたい私も知ってますけど
信仰する人は聞く質問じゃないんです
聞いてはいけません 失礼ですよ
例えばキリスト教を信仰しながら
キリスト教の信者さんでありながら
なんで神様が人間を作ったんですか？なんでこんなことするんですか？と聞いたら
それはすごい神を侮辱することになっちゃうんです
そんなことは神様のことだから
神様のこといちいち聞くなよと
あなたはもう作られたものだから
言われたとおりに謙虚で生きていれば救われるんだよという
それぐらいで終わっちゃうんですね
だから私たちみたいに
外の人がそういう失礼な質問をすぐ聞いたりするんです
しても そちらは専門家なのに答えられないんですよ
向こうも別にそんなことを考えようともしませんだから
あまりにも神様を非難することになりますから
だからとにかくなんでそういうややこしい状態が起こりますかというと
あの まず何かを証拠なしに信じるんですよ
だからそれは人間の智慧の世界で問題だとお釈迦様もおっしゃってるんですね
例えば このドアの外にキリンさんがいると
私は言います キリンさんがいますよと
信じなさいよと それで皆様方
はい 信じますよと で 言ったところでいくらでも喋れますね
キリンさんはまあどれ大きいですか？もうどんな色のキリンさんですか？あるいは置物として使えるものですか？何なのかとかね
それからキリンさんについて喋ると
やっぱりそういうキリン
ドアの外にキリンさん
キリンがいる さんと言うかどうか分かりませんだけど
あの キリンという動物がいますよ
信じなさいと言ったところで
仏教の立場はそうですか
調べましょうと 調べましょうと
調べていたならば それはまあ餌をあげるべきかないかとか
それは後の話なんですよ
キリンは葉っぱ食べてるんだから
あんた方葉っぱ集めてくださいと言ったらいるかないかもしれないで
一生懸命葉っぱ集めたりする
それは仏教の見方はそういう見方じゃなくて
本当かないかと まず調べる
ですから この信仰という題をなしに
初めから論理的で始まっちゃうんですね
だから仏教は初めから終わりまで論理的に行くんです
それであの面白いエピソードがあります
これ エピソードと言ったってのも
これは経典なんですが
この中部経典という経典がございまして
そちらで あの 何番目かとはちょっと思い出せませんだけど
あの 象の足跡という名前の経典なんですね
象の足跡 それで経典 2つあります
大と小 で この大ではなくて小という名前をつけているお経
経典なんです その経典はこの大変
あの まあ面白い経典で
あの このジャーナソーニというものすごい金持ちのバラモン人がいたんです
すごいもう大金持ちで
バラモン人だから宗教家でしょうね
ですから いろいろ宗教なことをやって
結構金儲けしていたでしょうと思いますけど
まあ祈祷やらいろんなことをやって
とにかくすごい豊かな有名な人で
彼がこのかなり贅沢しているんですよ
出かける場合は 特別に彼の特色っていうのは
もうかなりもう色にこだわって
もうよくカラーコーディネートするんですよ
だいたい白い色が好きで
白い馬 2つつけてつけてる白い馬車
それで馬車の中のインテリアも全部白い色で
すべてインテリアまで作って
それから馬にあのハーネスとかいろいろつけますね
あの体に出す なんて言いますか
そういう馬の体につけている
このつかめる あのあの
あ 手綱とかね それは全部白い色で統一しているんです
それは自分も白い服を着て
白いターバンを巻いて
まあ出かけるときは出かけると
そうするとかなりもうかなり贅沢で豪華で
もう派手に見えるんですよ
そこら辺にあるものは何でもいいんだから
どんな馬でもいいんですよということは
その人にとってはそれはできません
その人は昼 出かけた時は彼のまあよく知ってる行者がいたんですよ
有名な行者が この行者だから
あの彼とは全く正反対で修行しているんですよ
で 名前はピローティカという名前なんですけど
まあそこに捨てたなんか布切れ一つ腰に巻いて
ただそれだけで 修行して歩き回ってるんです
だから性格的にはすごい正反対で
でもこの二人がすごいお互いの知り合いなんです
この贅沢のバラモン人が出かけた時
自分と全く正反対の生き方をしているこの行者に出会ったんです
で やったら行者に君どこへ行って帰ってるんですかと
どこへ行ってきたんですか？と聞いたら
私はこの釈迦さんに挨拶しててもう帰ってる時ですよと
だからこの行者たちだから
あまり宗教にこだわらなかったんです
それはインド文化のすごく今はないんだけど
昔だとすごくいいところなんですよ
すごい柔軟性がありまして
で どこでも行くんです
だからピローティカ行者が別に仏教の信者さんではなくて
別な宗教の信仰していたんだけど
他の行者たちも他の宗教家たちにも挨拶したり
会ったり話したりする
自由に で 私はお釈迦様に会って挨拶して帰っている時ですよと言ったら
君どう思いますかね？この釈尊という人は
これはすごい人ですかね
そんなにも とこの行者に聞くんですね
聞いたら行者がすごく怖くなっちゃって
あなたは何を聞くんですかと
私のようなものに お釈迦様はすごい人ですか？とかね
そんな判断できる状態じゃないんだと
自分が 自分にとってはもうあまりにももう上の人で
尊い人で もうそんな判断できるわけじゃないんだと
言ったら あんたよくも
で なんでそう言うんですか？と言ったら
この国でみんなに褒められてる人々が釈迦尊のことを褒めているんだと
みんなに尊敬されている人々が釈迦尊のことを褒めているんだと
ですから 私にそんなことを聞いたってもとんでもない失礼だと
言ったら このバラモン人があんたは余計に釈尊のことを褒めるのではないかと
何か訳でもありますかと
そんなにも褒めるために
別に信じてもないんですよ
仏教徒でもないんです
それは訳でもありますかと聞いたら
まあ一つはあるんだと
私は釈尊に会ういろんな人々のことを見ていたんだと
このインテリ中のインテリのバラモン人たちが
お釈迦様と論争をしようと
いろんなもう考え方を作って
質問を作って じゃあ今度は論争してやるぞと行くんだと
行って挨拶してお釈迦様と話を交わして
何の質問もしないで礼をして帰るんだと
お釈迦様の話に納得して論争しようとも思い出すこともしないんだと
それをバラモン人のそれでシャトリア族
いわゆる王家の人々 それまですごいインテリの人々がいるんだから
そのインテリの人々も
またもう釈尊の言うことはもう論争して破ってやるぞと
もう自慢して行くのは行くんだけど
行ってから普通の挨拶終わるところでもう釈尊の話を信じて帰っちゃうんだと
質問しようともしないんだと
それで他のサイキョの人々も
またカースト 4つありましたから
インドでね あのワイシェというカーストの人々も
シュードラというカーストの人々も
もうどんなどの 4種類の人々がどのように質問をして論争しようとしてお釈迦様に会っても
結局挨拶ぐらいで終わってしまっちゃうんだと
挨拶でお釈迦様でちょっと普通の会話交わしたところで
お釈迦様の話を信じて帰っちゃうんだと
だからそれを見たら お釈迦様はすごいと決めなくちゃいけないんだと
それで彼がたとえ言うんですよ
もしでっかい牙もついているオスのゾウを探している人が森に入ったとする
森に入ったら ものすごいバカでかいゾウの足跡を見つかるんだと
あまりにも大きな足跡見つけたらわかるでしょう
ものすごい大きなゾウが森の中にいるいること
だから私はその 4つの足跡を見て
お釈迦様はものすごい人だともう決めたんだと
それはたとえなんですね
だから私たちもそうでしょう
例えば森にね 日本の森ではないんだけど
例えばアフリカの森でも入ったところで大きな足跡を見たら
やっぱりこれはすごい大きな象ではないかとすぐ決めるでしょうに
クマのクマの足跡でも見たら
ああ これ結構百五十キロぐらいのクマではないか
クマではないかとか決めるでしょうに
足跡を見たら まあそれで間違いなしと決めちゃうんです
そういうことで その人もそれで私は間違いなしと決めたんだと
このバラモン人に言うんですね
そう言われたら そのバラモン人
このジャーヌ僧尼さんがその話を聞いて
ああ そうですか やっぱり素晴らしいですね
お釈迦様と言って そんな素晴らしい人に礼をしなくちゃいけないと思って
その場で馬車から降りて
お釈迦様がいる方へ頭を下げて礼をするんですよ
礼をして せっかくもう自分に何か用事があって出かけたでしょうに
その用事ももうそれは取り消しにして
じゃあこのままお釈迦様に会ってみますと言ってお釈迦様に会いました
会って なんで私は私のような有名な人がお釈迦様に会った
会ったんですかというと
まあこういう出来事があった
私の友人のあるピローティカという行者が
私にこの４つの象の象の４つの足跡のたとえで
お釈迦様は素晴らしい人と説明してくれたんだと
だから来たんだよと言ったら
お釈迦様の答えは あのピローティカ君がたとえ説明していないんだと
あれは間違いだと だからピローティカという行者がお釈迦様のことを間違って説明しているんだと
というのお釈迦様の反応なんですね
ただ このバラモン人はどういうことですかと聞いたところで
もしこの探検する人が鋭い知恵のある人であるならば
足跡が大きいだけででっかい象だと決めませんと
なぜならば あの象にもたくさん種類がいるんですよ
今はほとんど絶滅状態になってもういないんですが
いくつかの種類があるんですね
このワーマニカという象の種類があるんじゃないかと
ワーマニカっていうのは背がすごく短いんですよ
高くないんです それで足はすごく太い
足の周りがすごく大きい
もしかすると その足跡は背が低い
ワーマニカという種類の象かもしれません
それからメスかもしれません
オスではなく だから足跡を見ただけで決めるんじゃないんだと
それで正しく真理を探す人だったら
足跡で決めないで さらに森の中に入ってみるんだと
さらに森の中に入ってみたら
結構高いところの枝なんか折ってる跡が見えるんだと
ものすごい高いところの木の枝なんか折っている
象は食べるんだから それでも証拠は 2つ揃ってるんですよ
すごい大きい足跡とすごい高いところの枝を切って食べていること
そうすると背が短い象でないゾウさんでないことは確かなんですね
背がすごく高い でも賢者というか
知恵のある人はそれで決めませんと
その証拠を 2つねじっただけで
なぜかというと またウッチャカーラーリカという象の種類がありまして
足が太くて背がすごい
もう細くて高いんですよ
いわゆる足だけ長くて体そんな大きいわけでもないんです
それで牙はない 牙は出てこない種類
もしかするとその象かもしれません
ですから 証拠を 2つねじってももうダメですよと
さらに調べなくちゃいけないんだと
さらに森の中に入ってみると
入ってみると 足跡も見える
上の枝切って取っているところも見える
それで牙で木の高いところを刺しているところも見える
もう証拠揃ってるでしょ
大きな足跡があります
かなり背が高いという証拠を取っている
牙もあることももうわかるでしょう
もうもうもう決めてもいいんでしょうかね
お釈迦様はダメですと
それぐらい証拠あってもダメです
なぜかというと うっちゃいかねるかという種類の象がいるんだと
それも雌象なんですよ
この体を長くて あまり体格あるわけじゃなくて
足はもう足の周りは大きい
上は細い で 胴体はそんなもう大きいわけでもないんですけど
細い牙があります で それも雌そうな象なんですね
だから決めませんと それだけで
それだけ智慧のある人はさらに調べてみるんだと
調べてみたら 自分の目で見えるんだと
バカでかい大きなオスゾウがすごい立派な牙を持って
そこら辺に歩いたり座ったり寝たり
枝を取って食べたりしているのを自分の目で見るんだと
見たところで決めるんだと
私は今までたどってきたこのいろんな跡が
このゾウが作ったものでしょうと
そこまであのたとえ説明しないと私のことを褒めたことにならないんだと
そこで仏教はどこまで物事を信じることは嫌いが嫌うかと
そのたとえでわかるんです
自分で確かめなきゃ もうどうにもならないと
そこでお釈迦様はそのたとえを置き換えて
ずっとあの あの 最近のバラモン人に説法するんですよ
まず 頭の良い人々が 頭鋭い人々が私のところに来るんだと
来ていろんな質問したり
反論したり 論争したり
私と話してみるんだと
話してみたところで 私が喋っていることは真理であると
ものすごく納得いくんだと
やっぱりこれはもうその通りで真理だよと納得いくんだと
でも納得いってもそれで物足りないんだと
それでその人はこういうふうに考えるんだと
やっぱりこれぐらい真理は正しいと私は納得しているんだから
これは自分で試さないと
自分で実験してみないと意味がないんだと思って出家するんだと
出家してお釈迦様がおっしゃっている
この大変いろんな戒律システムがありまして
このお釈迦様がおっしゃっているこの戒をきれいに守るようになるんだと
その戒を守るようになったら
心は穏やかになって 心の苦しみが消えちゃって
ものすごく幸せを感じるようになるんだと
でも それで止まってはいけませんと
それから彼があの瞑想を始めるんだと
瞑想が始めると この禅定がありますね
第１ ２ ３ ４まで そういう禅定なんか味わって
で この上ない喜悦感 幸福感
経験するんだと でもそれでも納得いってはいけません
それで彼が次に智慧を開発しようと努力するんだと
智慧を開発したところで自分の過去を見えてくるんだと
自分が過去生でどこで生まれて
どんなように生まれていたんですかと
それで限りなく もういろんな過去生を自分体験できるようになるんだと
それでも終われないんだと
終わってはいけませんと
それでその人にまた天眼という能力がついてきて
それも智慧なんですね
いろんな生命がそのその業によって生まれて死ぬこと
死んでまた生まれ変わること
それはいろんな生命がね
生まれて死んで また生まれて
また死んでいう この輪廻の構造を見えてくるんだと
それでも物足りないんだと
次にその人はさらに頑張って
自分の心にあるすべての煩悩をなくして
心をきれいに解脱するんだと
で 解脱するところで あ
なるほど お釈迦様がおっしゃっている解脱はこういうものでしょうかと納得するんだと
だから仏教で納得っていうのは
そこまでかなりきついというか
厳しいというか この普通の世の中でのこの中途半端で信じるというところじゃないんです
誰かの写真見せて これを空中浮遊しているんですよと言ったら
ああ やっぱりみんなで信じましょうと
だって写真があるんだからって
そんなレベルじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様が希望している論理レベルと現代我々の論理レベルっていうのは
テレビで言ったんだからとすぐ信じるでしょうに
写真があるんだからすぐ信じるでしょうに
そこで UFO の写真とかあるでしょ？テレビですごい番組やるんですね
今はもう ８月になってくると
お化けの番組とかどんどん出るでしょうに
まあ証拠あることあること
それでまあこういう心霊写真が出ましたとかね
だけど私たちっていうのは
まあそれぐらいのことで
まあはい 真実だ 本当のことだと信じるもんなんですよ
だから簡単に信じるんだから
逆にどうなるんですかね
簡単に騙されるんです
簡単に信じる人はものすごいとっても簡単に騙されるんです
そこであの象の例えに戻りますけど
象がオスかメスかということは
目で見なきゃわからないでしょ
知る方法はないんです
現代科学的な方法があるんだと言ったっても
それはもう実験 試験管持って森に入るわけじゃないんだからね
尿のサンプルを取ってみて
尿のサンプルを取ったって
これなかなか無理ですけどね
まあ妊娠しているメスだったらわかるんだけど
そうでない限りはそんな尿のサンプルを取ったにはわからないもんですよ
オスかメスかぐらいでも
ですから まあそこまで判断を
何といいますか サスペンドと言うんですけど
何て言いますか 疑うんじゃなくて
もう えっ？保留する 判断を保留して
さらにさらに証拠を探していけばいいんです
そこで判断するのはもうはっきりと
もうこれはこれと もう他の結論が出せないんだというところなんですね
だからこのお釈迦様の話っていうのは
大体あの そういう態度で話してたんですよ
自分の国はこのお釈迦様の仏教は外国で始めた場合は一番最初にスリランカという国でしたから
スリランカに伝道のお坊様方が行って
初めて教えた経典はこの象の芦屋等の経典だそうです
我々の歴史書にそういうふうに書いているんです
昔書いている歴史上なんですけど
で スリランカという島に来て
王様やらその人々は住みてもらって
この仏教は紹介しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
仏教はなかったんだから
それでこのこの象の足跡という名前の経典をチュンラハッティパドーブスッタとかパーリ語で言うんですけど
それの大経典ではなくて
小という経典で説法したんだと
やっぱり私は気持ちわかるんですよ
まるっきり仏教を知らない人々にとって
信じなさいよと責めるんではなくて
信じなくても結構ですよと
判断は保留してくださいと
とことんチャレンジしてみてくださいと
その方が安心だと私は思いますよ
やっぱり信じ信じなきゃあかんかどうかね
そんな困ったりしちゃうと精神的に悩みが生まれるんですよ
強迫観念とかね いろいろ出てくるんだから
そういうことで このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
ずっとこの自由みたいな
このフリーというかね
束縛はない だから あの一般的な宗教にある徹底的に信じなさいと
無条件で信じなさいというのは
仏教から見ればとんでもない脅しではないかというふうに感じることもどうしようもないんですね
これは脅しでしょうと
だから私は個人的に そうやって宗教的な対立ができた出た場合は
何のことない あんた人を脅してどうするんですかと
それぐらいのこと脅されると思ってるんですかと
地獄に落ちるそうとかね
で 日本のね 若い人々をね
前はテレビでも見ていたんだけどね
まあもう味見 味見 味見
地獄ですか なんとかに落ちるんだと
自分の開祖様に悪口言ったらとかね
それで脅したりする で
やっぱりあれはすごいこの原始的な思考なんですね
だから今の時代  21世紀やといっても
心は原始状態だから それすごい困ったもんですよ
だからこの現代の方々の問題っていうのは
この建物は作っているし
機械はいっぱい持っているし
道具は持ってるんだけど
頭は原始状態で原始人と何の変わりもない
はい 信じますと 原始人もそうでしょうね
太陽が出てくるとあまりにも驚いちゃって
やっぱり神様ではないかと拝んだりする
で 太陽神様ですってのは
はい そうですよと ヒンドゥー教でもスーリヤデーヴァというような
南インドにありますけど
すごい大きな神社というか
お寺というかね 太陽を神様にして拝むと
だからこの何でも信じる
という性格は 心の原始的な状態で
やっぱりあの 調べて調べて実験して試していくのは一向に構わないと
仏教の立場なんですね
そんなに怖がる必要はないんだと
罰が当たると思う必要もないんだと
ただ真理知りたいと 本当のことを知りたいと
本当のことを知って何が悪いんですかと
という態度でとことん調べていくような能力が人間にあってほしいなというのは仏教的な立場なんですね
ですから このお釈迦様の言葉で
お釈迦様はいつでも言うのは
この智慧のある人々が出てこいと
それはなんとなくお釈迦様差別ではないかと
智慧がない人はどうしますか？と
なんでそういう言葉を言いますかというと
やっぱりそう言わざるを得ない状態になっているんだから
だから あ 怖いと あ 尊いと
こんなことを聖者を宗教家を疑っちゃったら罰が当たるんではないかとということがあっちゃうと困るんですね
それも昔からのね インド文化であった一つの特色で
この聖者を侮辱しちゃうととんでもない罰が当たるんだと
聖者の機嫌が悪くなることでもしたら
とんでもないことになるんだというストーリーはいっぱいあります
で 日本訳もありますね
マハーバーラタとかね
そういうマハーバーラタの日本訳でもあります
ストーリーばっかりなんですよ
あまりにも面白くないストーリーで私は読みませんけど
読んでやったらご飯も食べられなくなるほどストーリーなんですけど
結構あるんですけど その中でものすごい散々出てくるんですよ
この聖者に失礼なことをして
すごく罰が当たったとか
今のヒンドゥー教で信仰している神様の名前はラーマなんですね
で ラーマっていうのはこの昔なんとかいった
まあ誰かの人なんですが
で この今の宗教の物語もそうやって
このラーマという人が誰かの聖者にちょっと失礼なことをして
その聖者に怒られちゃって
それでもう追い出されて
自分の国から で そこで苦労した物語があって
それでまた自分の国に戻ったと
それぐらいのストーリーなんですけど
そのだから今 ヒンドゥー教の一番メインな大事な物語なんですけど
それもやっぱりそうやって聖者をからかっちゃったらもうただで済まないんだという
もう話なんですね そういう風に脅し入れて置いちゃう
置いちゃうと 人間が自分の探検能力を失っちゃうんですね
自分で調べてみようということがなくなっちゃうんですね
だから西洋の場合は このなんで西洋はの方が我々よりもすぐ発展してしまったかというと
西洋でものすごい脅しの宗教があったのに
キリスト教という殺しちゃうんですよ
脅すだけじゃなくて それなのにみんなチャレンジして科学的な研究したんですね
だからまあとことんチャレンジして
いろんな研究したところで
いろんなものを発見して発見していったんですね
いくらなんでも地球は丸いんだと
丸いと言ったら殺すぞと
でもしょうがないということで
やっぱり丸いことは丸いと
だからこの どちらにするかなということが未だに解決できない問題なんですけど
やっぱりそのポイントだけ
人間は真理を探すべきです
真理は何なのかと とことんチャレンジして調べるべきなんですよ
だからお釈迦様は自分のことを菩薩の時代で自分のことをこう言うんですよ
キンサッチャガレーシ
これ自分のことをこう言うんです
これ悟る前 菩薩の時代で
自分がキンサッチャガレーシでしたと
キンというのはワット
サッチャっていうのは真理
真理は何かと探検者 いわゆる探求する者
だから自分が真理は何なのかと
もう探求していったんだと
で それだけじゃなくてもう一つ
自分にお釈迦様 自分のことをこう言うんですよ
キンクサラガレーシ ...検索クサラからですね
クサラっていうのは善
善という意味で正しいもの
正しい生き方 真理は何なのか
正しいものは何なのかと
私は探求したんだと そういうことで
この私 人間というのは
いくら時代経っても この人間の脳細胞にあるこの能力はやっぱり大事にしなくちゃいけないんですよ
やっぱりこの真理って何なのかと調べてみると
探してみると チャレンジしてみると
その機能は育てるべきなんですね
やっぱり人が言うことを何でも信じるんだったら
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃうんですよ
信じやすい人は当然騙しやすい
それで逆に信じやすい人は悪いんだったら
何でも疑う人はどうですかね
何も信じません それもアホなんですよ
何でも疑う 何にも認めませんと
何も信じませんと これいとも簡単でしょう
どんなバカにもできますから
だから何でも信じるぞという人も
何も信じません 何も認めませんという人ももう同じレベルなんですね
別にそれありがたいわけじゃないんです
だから私はそれぐらいにちょっと注意したいところなんですが
あの やっぱりそんな簡単に信じるなよということは
何でも疑って疑って疑いだけの人生いいわけじゃないんで
それも疑うのはいとも簡単
いい あんた言ってること信じませんと
ほか何か言ったら いえ
信じませんと 人がいくら証拠を持ってきたのでも信じませんと
それはいとも簡単だから
信じませんと言うためにはかなり能力が必要ですよ
あなたのことを信じませんと言うためにも
こういうわけで こういうわけで
こういうことで こういうことで信じませんと言わなくてはいけないんですよ
ですから 何が必要かというと
前に消した言葉なんですけど
論理性 論理性は必要になっちゃうんです
まあ難しくなってしまいましたけど
まあこれは頭がもう熱すぎて動かないんです
笑 [咳]まああの論理性って何でしょうかね
あの論理 そこら辺 私はあまり喋ろうとは計画を立ててないんですけど
難しいしね 難しいのは話じゃなくて
この例を出すのはすごい難しいんです
あの それにはいろいろ勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
大雑把で言えば 私たちは勉強している
この知識 学校で勉強しているもの
科学とかね そういうものは大雑把で言えば論理的なものなんですね
特に あの この科学系で我々が勉強するものは
まあまあ大体論理的なんですね
だからそれはもう絶対的に論理とは私は言いたくないんです
科学は まあ私の嫌な言葉かもしれませんだけど
まあ現代科学はまあそこそこ論理的ではないかと
だからこのそこそこ論理性あるんだから我々の役に立ってるんですよ
科学の発明やらね 発見やら
であの例えばこの科学と関係ない
ただ考古学はありますね
で 考古学で このまあ お墓を掘ってみる
古いお墓 何かね ピラミッドでも何でもいいんですけど
古墳でも何でも で 古いお墓を掘ったところで
もう出てきた骨なんか見て
これは何年前のものですかと
で 考古学っていうのはそんな科学的なものじゃないんだから
掘ればいいでしょうし
で まあそれだけのことなんですけど
やっぱり骨拾ったところで
これは何年前のものかというと
やっぱり科学は助けてくれないと
それで科学者がいろんな武器を持ってきて
いろんな機械を持ってきて
それにいろんな方法で
例えばこのカーボンというね
計算する方法がありまして
で そういう方法で一部をもう壊して壊れてしまいますけど
それでこれぐらい古いだろうと
決めたりする で その年代を計算する場合は
そちらにはいくらかは論理性があるんです
例えばカーボンの放射性ですか
それはもうこれぐらいの割合で減っていくんだとということを知ってるんだから
今この物質のその放射性はどれぐらいかと見て
それから引き算で あ これぐらいの古いものやと決めちゃうんですね
でもそれもぴったし決めることはできないんですよ
まあ大雑把でこれぐらいではないかと
だから 例えば日本で発掘するものは
何でも日本最高なものやと放送するでしょ
なんどんなくそなものを発掘したっても
日本最高なものだと だからニュース全部並んでみたら
なんだバカなことを言ってるんじゃないかと思っちゃいますかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりなんであんなことを学者まで言うんですかというと
そこら辺は論理がないんですよ
かっこつけないんですよ
一番古い最高のものを発見できなかったら
それで余計に年代を入れちゃうんです
ある日本の同じ考古学者なんですけど
まあこれやりすぎやと
非科学的だと そんな感動的な物語はありませんと
でも自分が言うことをだから誰も認めませんと
やっぱり 1万年古いものを見つけても
日本最高なものを見つかったんだと言わなくちゃいけないんだと
だからということも話を聞いたことがありますけど
だからいくらか論理性があって
いくらか もういい加減な感情が入ったりする
で あの まあとにかくまあそういうことは置いておいて
普通に我々が勉強しているものっていうのは
学校で大学で勉強しているものっていうのは論理的な話なんですね
だから勉強しやすい でも
あの なんで科学的なものっていうのはじりじりと変わっちゃうんですかね
それはこの完全論理性は持ってないんですよ
何か何かデータを取ったところで
すぐ結論を出す 特にこの科学の世界で
特に科学といっても この宇宙のことを見る世界
ちょっと調べてみてください
ほんのわずかなデータでとことんとことん推測して
推測的 推測して考えてストーリー作っちゃうんですよ
今コンピューターシミュレーションというものができるんだから
まあこういう風に宇宙が現れて
こういう風に星が出てきてとかね
ものすごいインパクト強くストーリー作っちゃいます
あれはすべてインチキですね
で なぜかというと それは頭で考えた夢の世界で
撮った情報はほんのわずかで
だからこの この間 なんか日本で昔いたなんか動物の骨が見つかった
見つかったんだけど 小さな哺乳類の
ちょっと骨の一部しか見つかってないんですよ
それで全部他の骨格も決めちゃって
もう皮膚まで入れて もう全部動物も作っているんですね
だからあの一部だけデータはあるんだけど
そこからすべて推測で
補ってしまっちゃうんですね
だから皆様はもう恐竜の模型見てるでしょうね
ティラノサウルスやらまあね
でも私は恐竜の皮膚は何色ですかと
知らんはずでしょうに
見たことはないんだから
骨は見たことがあるんだけど
だからそれにまた科学的な知識を入れて入れて
科学的っていうのは論理的な知識を入れて
まあこれぐらい骨だったらこれぐらい筋肉でないと支えられませんとかね
で そうやって計算しながら体を作るんだけど
そこまではいいんですが
皮膚はどうしますかと
もしティラノサウルスの皮膚はカバの皮膚のようにスルスルだったらどうしますか？で
今はワニの皮膚のように作ってますけど
本当にその通りかわからないでしょ
まあそれもどうか分かりませんけども
爬虫類というんですからね
まあしょうがないんですけど
ですからこのこの科学の世界でも
かなり芸術的な 感情的な夢の物語も入ってるんですよ
だからみんなに人気あるのは
この論理的なものじゃなくて
感情的な 芸術的な夢の物語なんですね
映画で恐竜 恐竜を戦わせてみたりする
音も出したりする でも音は本当ですかね
あの音は 形まではいいかもしれませんだけど
音の再現は全く不可能だと思います
科学的には  そういうふうなことで
この私 今おかげで助かっている科学の世界にしても
あの厳密に論理的というよりも
大体大雑把で論理なんです
で それで仏教の立場は真理知りたければ
まあ大雑把な論理でもいいんですけど
決めたもので止まるんじゃなくて
いつでもこの判断を まあとりあえずこうではないかということでいいんですよ
とりあえず やっぱり流動状態で
新しい情報が見つかり次第もう変えますよということでいかなくちゃいけないんですね
だからその立場はまあ宗教を通しても使っているのはただ仏教だけなんですね
その科学的な立場 徹底的に調べてみる
だから怖いということはないんだと
だから仏教の場合は 宇宙は丸いか四角いか平らかというのは
それはまあお釈迦様には興味がない
なぜかというと 人間にとっては別に関係ないんです
宇宙はもう地球は丸くても四角くてもどうでもいいんだからね
人間にとって問題は自分の心の問題で
自分が幸せかないか 自分が苦しんでいるんでしょうか
あるいはすごい最高に楽しんでいるんですかという
そのところになってくると
人間ってのはえらいおかしいんですよ
人に言われると あなたは本当に素晴らしい幸せな人間ですよと
ああ そうですか 納得いくんですね
ある日本の宗教家の話を聞いてるんだけど
あなた方は光の子であると
神の分身である なんて素晴らしいかという
みんな納得するんです
そんな簡単に納得していいのかと
自分が幸せかなんか自分で知らないんですかね
それぐらい我々は自分のことになると全く論理性失っちゃうんですよ
全くもう無知な人間になっちゃうんです
顕微鏡で何か見てちゃんと研究しなさいと言ったら
厳密に客観的に研究する
お医者さんはね まあ細い神経までつなげたりする
厳密にすごい難しいんですけど
血管ももう縫うでしょうに
切れた血管はまたつなげて
神経もつなげておいて
それで見えません 血液は流れてくるはもう同じ色でしょうに
神経ももう血管もなんだかんで
もう極めて難しい だから厳密に顕微鏡でもつなげて
またテレビモニターでも見ながらよくやるんですよ
本当にものすごい もう技というか
もうすごいもんなんですね
それなのに自分のことになると完璧な無知な状態になる
だから仏教はそこら辺に研究課題にしているんです
自分を研究しなさいと
それも科学者が科学を研究するような感じで
地理学者は地面のことを研究するような感じで
生物学者は生物をどのように調べてみるかと
それぐらいの客観性で自分のことも探検してみなさいと
だから仏教と科学の違うところは
この研究課題なんですね
で 科学の場合は自分のことを放っておいて外の世界を研究する
だから いくら研究していったっても
人間はそのままで だから21世紀になってるんだけど
我々の脳の働きは未だに原始状態で脳は成長しない
物は発展する 洞窟で住んでいた我々は
今高層ビルで生活住んでいる
でも洞窟にいた人がそのままで高層ビルの中の部屋の中にいるだけなんです
自分のこと何一つ分かってないんです
ですから この科学発展は人間の役に立ちません
お釈迦様の研究は人間の役には立ちます
その差がはっきりしているんです
だから私はこの仏教は科学的だ
科学的だというのは 科学だとは言わない
仏教も科学ですよということは言わないんです
科学的ですよというのは
やっぱり研究課題は違いますから
で 科学者は例えば地球の重さは測ったりするでしょ
いろんな計算して計算して
まあこれぐらい重いでしょうと
まあ合ってるかもしれませんけど
だから我々にとってそれはどんな役に立つんでしょうかと
自分の心の黒さを測ったことがありますかね
それは測ったことはないんですね
調べたこともない そういうことだから
自分で何なのかと厳密に客観的に
論理的に調べて調べていきなさい
うん これはものすごい大きい課題ですから
そこら辺で淡々と次のポイントいくつか言ってもう終了したいと思いますけど
ちょっと あの 大体日本でも皆様も大体に同じ気持ちだと思いますけどね
あんまり 例えば日本の方々
このあんまりこの西洋的にこのもう論理っていうのはちょっと
あまり好ましくないとね
あんまりにも激しく理屈ばっかしでとかね
という気持ちもあると思いますけど
本当はこの左脳の理屈ばっかしで何の味もないんですよ
だからって右脳の方の感情ばっかしで
それでいいんですかと
それはあまり意味がないんですよ
どちらでも真理には近寄らないんですね
理屈ばっかし働かせちゃうと
ただの空想になってしまっちゃうんですね
何も得られなくなっちゃう
それで感情だけで生きていると
何一つ分かったことにならないんですね
自分の好き嫌いで 自分の感情で
だからまあ これはものすごい失礼な分け方なんですけど
もう正しくないんです
この分け方は 私は分けたくないんだけど
西洋の方はものすごい論理的だと
理屈ばっかし 左の寄りだと
やっぱり東洋は右の方寄りだと
思いがち場合もありますけど
それも決して合ってるわけではないんだけど
そういう現代我々の脳の働き
見るとどちらでも空想になっているんです
論理 理屈 例えば今医学の場合はね
体は論理的に分析して分析して
機械扱いして いろいろなことをやっているでしょうに
それで本当に治療になるかならないかと
で 大体治療にならなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
論理だけだから 理屈だけだから
で 感情だけで言っちゃったら
また意味がなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの現代まで人間が感情を育てる
あるいは理屈を育てるという 2つやってくるんですが
仏教から見れば このどちらでも空想で終わっているんですね
そういうことに例を出すとすごく難しいし
私はもうそこまで例を調べてはないんですけど
このまあ理屈だけ考えちゃうと
どんな理屈もできます
で まあ例えば今Gなんとかというサミットがあるんですね
で それでこのソ連はアメリカのこのミサイルディフェンスシステムというものにはもう反対すると
そういうリポートする人々が
どのようなリポートするかというと
ソ連というのはとんでもないことを言っているんだというふうな感じで
ミサイルディフェンスシステムというミサイルを作ることが正しいと
言いながら それに理由に持ってくるのは北朝鮮
北朝鮮がミサイルを作ったらどうするんですかと
だから論理的に考えているんですよ
北朝鮮がもしミサイルを作ったらどうしよう
あ 大変だ ですから 我々はものすごいバカでかいスケールでミサイルを作ってやるぞと
あれはその人々が論理的やと思ってるんだけど
私から見ればもうあまりにも無知な理屈に見えるんですね
だからソ連のプーチンさんがこの集まる前にささっと走って北朝鮮に行って
その人と話し合って だからいくらか論理的に何かやろうとしてるんですよ
だからアメリカ側がどんな理屈持ってくるかというと
北朝鮮は良くないんだと
だから私は人類をすべて殺すために道具を作るんだという理屈で持ってくるんだから
じゃあそれだったら北朝鮮の人からね
もうやめますと約束もらっちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
その人とさっとそちらに飛んで話し合って
そういう結論を持ってサミットに参加するんですね
なぜかというと やっぱりそんな危ないことを
やばいことをやめましょうという
考え方だと思いますけど
だからこのこれからの世界っていうのは
この武器開発ではもう生きていられないんですよ
もういい加減やめた方がいいんですよ
人殺しことは でもこの理屈型の人間が人殺すことは正しいと
平気で論理作っちゃうんで
あれは論理的じゃないんですよ
殺すのも論理的に正しいし
殺さないのも論理的に正しいというんだから
だから論理だけっていうのは何の役にも立たないんですよ
だからこのみんなも誰に頭にも浮かばないのは
この違う道があるんじゃないかと
平和を維持するためにどうすればいいんですかと
例えば この第三世界の国々の借金とかね
それはどうするんですかと
それは話そうともしないと
死ぬ連中は死んでもいいと
我々にも大きな問題があるんです
武器はどれぐらい作ればいいかという
そういうのはもうアホのいいところでしょうに
だからこのもう一つ思考があるはずなんですけど
それは頭に出てこない
あまりにも論理という論理というか
理屈ですね 理屈ばっかしで働いているんだから
事実見えなくなっちゃうんですね
だから例えばまあ私は答えで言うんですけど
そうやって大きな人間
国々の人々がね もう集めて
まあ地球はこれからどうなるでしょうかと
どうすればより豊かな世界になるんでしょうかと
無駄な費用をね どういうふうにすればなくすんでしょうかと
そういうふうには考えようとも微かにでも思わないんですね
それも理屈にしたっても
結局もうそうやってヘリックスで終わってしまっちゃう
例えば日本も頭で妄想しちゃったら
まあ北朝鮮がもしミサイル一つ撃っちゃったら
日本に向かってどうしましょうかと
まずそれを仮定する それからそれを信じる
信じたところでもう怖くてもういてもたってもいられなくなっちゃうんでしょ？ミサイルが飛んできたらどうしますか？だったらもうあっちこっち
また北朝鮮に撃ち返すためにミサイルを置いておかなくちゃいけないんだ
ディフェンスシステムを作らなくちゃいけない
それからとことん考えてディフェンスシステムを作ったりする
すべての資源を最後はそこに行ってしまう
それで何年待っていてもなかなか撃ってこないし
こちらも撃ち返すこともできなくなっちゃうし
そこで 10年経っちゃうと
もう 10年じゃなくて５ ６
年経っちゃうと もうすっきりああいう機械は使えなくなる
で また新しく作り直さなくちゃいけない
そういうやり方はどこまでやるつもりですかね
日本が別にそんなことをやっているわけじゃないんだけど
このどのようにこの理屈が生まれて発展するかっていうことのいい例なんですよ
日本はまだやってないんだから
まだ実感していないんですね
北朝鮮からミサイルが飛んでくること
あの軍事世界で産業をやっている人々は
本当にそうやって この厳密にこの妄想っていうのは実際に思ってるんですよ
ものすごい具体的に思って
それからもう狂暴になって政府をいじめてお金出せと
で 例えばこのミサイルディフェンスシステムというものを作ったりしちゃうと
もしかするとアメリカが技術は素晴らしいんだから
ススミが飛んできちゃっても
すぐ 反応してミサイルがパッパッパッとね
花火のように出てくるようになる可能性もあります
アメリカの空のアメリカのロイックの空にススミが飛んできたんだと
それはコンピューターがもうすぐ反応して
あまりにも敏感なシステムで
まあまあですから このそういうふうに
このもう非現実的に ただ理屈ばっかり働かせちゃうと
そういうふうに無駄な世界
今の世界 そういう世界なんですね
日常 21世紀まで作った世界っていうのは
全て無駄 無駄だけの世界
理屈だけで働いて で 逆に感情だけだったら
映画やら美術だけ 絵画描くだけの世界になっちゃうんですね
例えばみんな芸術家になっちゃって
みんないろんな絵の具を持っていて
いろいろ絵画ばっかり描いていると
食い物はないと それも何の意味もないんですよ
音楽は楽しく聞こえるのはお腹がいっぱい食べた時なんですよ
食べるものもない状態で
ものすごい立派な絵画をそこ描いたんだとかね
それ何の役にも立ちません
ですから 感情的な世界も人間の役には立ちませんし
この我々のこの左のばっかし動かしているこの理屈の世界も人間の役に立ってないんですよ
結局 もう破滅の方向へ持っていくだけ
だから世の中 この全然脳細胞は発達しない
まず持ってる脳細胞も変に使っちゃって
もう破滅の方向へ持っていく
だからこのまあ我々は違う道があるんだと
違う道があるんだとずっとおっしゃってはいるんです
で かくて仏教は論理否定しているわけじゃ
仏教は厳密に論理的 厳密に論理的だから
もう空想的な理屈ばっかりやっているから
それはないんですよ それのお釈迦様はすごく反対するんですよ
それの一つのエピソードがあるんです
それも経典から出てくるストーリーで
ある ある人が宗教の行者なんですけど
いろんな宗教を探検している間で
もうお釈迦様のところにも入ってしまっちゃったんです
あの道場を巡りで 道場を巡る過程で
お釈迦様のところにも入って
そこで出家して瞑想を始めたんです
瞑想を始めたら この人にはいくらか統一心が統一してしまって
あの異次元的な いわゆる天界の神々というかね
天界の住人たちを見えるようになってきたんです
瞑想して もうある一定のレベルに行ったら
まあ見える いわゆる今風に言えば
あの 何て言いますか 何か霊能力みたいなもの付いちゃって
そこであまりにも美しい
この天界の神々のあまりにも美しい姿を見たりして
でも彼には音声はないんです
あのテレビの音声はミュートにしているような感じで
映像は見えるんだけど
音声はない 音は聞こえない
だから彼に実際にこの神々がそのあの
その時やっていることは見えるんです
ライブで生で見えてるんだけど
神々が喋ったり 踊ったり歌ったりするのは見えるんだけど
音は出てこないんですね
それでこの人はもうこれはお釈迦様から直接指導を受けて瞑想するわけじゃないんだから
お釈迦様のところに行って
お釈迦様に報告したんだよ
自分が瞑想していると
この神々がいろいろやっていることは見えるんだと
でも何喋っているか 何を歌っているかと聞こえないんだと
どうすれば自分には音声のチャネルもついてくるんですかと
聞いたらお釈迦様は全然何も言わなかったんです
何も言わなかったんです
それにすごく怒ったんです
この行者は これ嫉妬しているんだと
もし私に神々も見えて
神々の声も聞こえるようになったら
お釈迦様と同じ能力でしょ
嫉妬しているんだ だから教えてくれないんだ
いくらなんでも まあ後ででも教えてくれるだろうと
教えてくれなかったら
とにかくその方法ももう盗んでやってみるぞということで
まあ一緒に出家して 一人の比丘として生活しているんですよ
生活して修行するんだけど
なかなかこの能力ついてこない
いろんなお坊さんたちに聞いてみるんだけど
でもうまくいかない それでもう諦めて怒って原則するんですよ
原則として もう言いたい放題悪口を言うんです
仏教について 一体一番このお釈迦様気になった悪口があるんですね
お釈迦様はただの論理的に喋っているだけですよと
リクエストで喋ってるんだと
だからお釈迦様はすごく反対する
ものすごく嫌がると言ってもいいかもしれません
お釈迦様を怒らせる言葉なんです
この言葉は まだ長い文章ですけど
まだ長くありますけど
じゃあこれだけでいいです
タッカパリヤハタンサマノゴートもダンマンです
タッカっていうのはこの論理ロジック
いわゆる論理的に組み立てて
論理的に徹底的に組み立てて
サマナゴートもおってのお釈迦様のことをゴートマだからお釈迦様の名前は
まあこれ英語じゃないんだから大文字書く必要ないんですけど
まあ名前だからまあ大文字で書きましょう
ゴートマサマンのゴートマが
いわゆるお釈迦様が論理的に組み立てて組み立ててダンマンデーセーと説法してるんですよ
だから破れないんだから
それは悔しい お釈迦様が喋るとものすごい説得力あったし
あれはまあただ論理的に論理的に組み立てて組み立てて喋ってるだけですよと
そういうふうなことを言いふらしちゃったんですよ
この人が これ言われるとお釈迦様は結構ただでは済みません
もう大変な怖いんですよ
そんなこと言われたら
仏教の世界では で 彼がそんなことを言いふらしちゃって
まあ論理的に喋ってるだけですよと
お釈迦様にはその経験はないんだと
その言ってることはいわゆる実行して経験してるわけじゃないんだと
いわゆる口うるさいだけですよとね
今の言葉で言えばね ただ口うるさいだけです
よくベラベラベラベラ喋るんだと
で こうやって言って でももう一つ
彼がお釈迦様を批判非難するためにもう一言葉添える使える
まあ付け加えるんですよ
でも彼が言った通りにやってみるとなかなかうまくいくんだと
でも本人がただ理屈を組み立てて組み立てて喋ってるだけですが
でもやってみると まあその通りにはいくんだと
言ってる通りに それどういうことかというと
自分もちょっとやってみたんだから
やってみた部分は嘘ではなかったんですね
その話を広げたところで
まあお釈迦様はすごい
それにはもう認めたくはないし
ものすごいいきなり立ち上がって対立しちゃったんです
お釈迦さんにその報告が入ったところから
お釈迦さんははっきり言ったのは
あのアホが私を非難しようとして褒めているんだと
それぐらい頭が悪いんだと
人を馬鹿にするんだったらはっきり馬鹿に馬鹿にしなさいよということなんです
私を非難しようと思って賞賛しているんだ
それも論理的に崩しちゃったんだ
お釈迦様 この非難の言葉自体
だって お釈迦様がいい加減理屈ばっかり喋ってるんだけど
言ってることは実行すればその通りになるんだったら
それはお釈迦様の評賛になるでしょう
だからお釈迦様に自慢できるでしょう
でしょ？嘘じゃないでしょうと
言ったことは 言ったことは嘘じゃないでしょうと言えるでしょうに
だからまあそれ人をけなそうとしたっても
その方法さえもわかってないんだと
言ってお釈迦様はすごい
まあきつく攻撃したんですよ
ですごいきつくその人に攻撃して
あの世の経典でずっとストーリーはありますが
時間はなくなっちゃいますからね
そこら辺ちょっと省きますけど
どういうふうにも対立が起きちゃって
で 彼が他の聖者の他の宗教家のところに行ってね
その宗教の人が自分にはお釈迦様よりすごい超能力があるんだと
超能力自慢してるんですね
お釈迦様は全然超能力自慢はしない
超能力には反対だから
超越した能力は賛成するんだけど
超能力は反対です ですから
お釈迦様は論理的に喋ってみんなに悟りの道を教える
そういうことだから 他の宗教の人々は超能力を売り物にしちゃうんですね
するんだけど 誰も証拠は出さない
である行者が自分にはすごい超能力があるんだと
釈尊なんかはね 一つ超能力を見せちゃうと
私は 10個ぐらい見せてやるぞと
なんだ あんな釈迦っていうのは
まだまだ若いではないかという感じでお釈迦様のことを批判していたんですね
そこでこの人はすごく気に入って
やっぱりさすがいい先生に出会ったと
お釈迦様を馬鹿にするためにはいい人やと言って
まあお互いに話し合って
話して話を広げてしまって
一般人にも知られてしまって
そこでお釈迦様にチャレンジかけてるんだと
超能力はお釈迦様にはできなくて
ある行者にできるんだと
言ったところでお釈迦様は
この王様がまたその報告したんですね
言ったらお釈迦様 これはもうただで済まないんだという
お釈迦様はすごく怒ったでしょう
この言葉に 私はただ理屈ばっかり喋ってるんだと言うんだったから
じゃあ私はじゃあチャレンジ受けますと
挑戦状 誰に超能力あるかと
やってみましょうと言ってお釈迦様は場所を決めた
そういう場所でこの日に来て集めてくださいと王様に言って
あんたみんなを集めてみなさいと
ただ 王様が逆に困ったんですよ
なぜかって お釈迦様はそれを禁止しているんですね
特別な能力は いかなる理由があっても一般の人々に見せてはいけないと
お釈迦様は弟子たちにもみんなにもやってはいけませんと禁止していることを
お釈迦様はやるそうと言ったら
王様が困って 王様とお釈迦様
すごい仲が良かったんですね
困ってお釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様はそういうふうに言っても困るんじゃないかと
これやっぱりなしことにしましょうと
あの人が一人勝手にこの森の中で叫んだっても
関係ないでしょ お釈迦様にとっては
そんなことを気にする必要はないんだと
お釈迦様はもしちょっとだけでも超能力なんか見せちゃったらね
これ困ると なんで困るんですか？と
だってお釈迦様はみんなにそれを禁止しているでしょうにと
だから法律を犯すことになるんだと
仏教の法律 それお釈迦様自身で法律を犯しちゃったらもっと困りますよと言ったら
お釈迦様にもうお釈迦様も
もう何といいますか 下げません
もうお釈迦様は一番攻撃する言葉で批判されたんだから
お釈迦様は王様に じゃあ君に聞きますけど
君はいろいろ法律を作ってるでしょ
自分の国民に あんた守ってるんで
それは あんた破ったらどうしますか？といえ
私は法律を作ってるんだから
私にはその法律関係ないんだと
いわゆる王様が最高裁判官で
もう自分を調べる人がいない
自分が一般国民にこうやってはいけない
こうしてはいけない 泥棒してはいけないと言ってるだけで
だから法律は王に効かないでしょうと
聞きませんと 法律的にはと
だから私は法律を作る人やと
私は比丘たちにやってはいけないんだと言ってるんだけど
私もやってはいけないと言ってないんだと
だからやりますと で 王様に言うことも聞かないで
その場所で集めたんですが
あの行者は現れなかったんです
で お釈迦様はやっぱりまあそんなもんだと
私の前には来られないんだと
できれば運んででも連れてこいと
運んででも連れてくることはできなかったんです
その集会か そこでお釈迦様は特別な自分能力をみんなに見せてという話ですけど
まあとにかくそのストーリーは関係ないんだけど
そこでこの純粋に論理ばっかり喋ることは
仏教はどれほど嫌いっていたかという例なんですよ
あのお釈迦様さえも腹が立つんです
理屈ばっかりではないかと言われると
理屈ばっかりじゃないんです
だから この単なる理屈ばっかりで何の意味もない空想になる
単なる感情だけで事実から必ずずれてしまっちゃうんですね
例えば 私たちは勝手にあの人のことを嫌いですよと
気に入らないんだよと思ったら
それで終わっちゃう 嫌です
気に入らない 好きじゃない
そうすると その人がどんないいことをしても
どんな立派な人であろうとも
もう事実調べようとしないんですね
まあ嫌いだから嫌いですということで済みますね
そういうことで事実に至らなくなっちゃうんですね
理屈だけだったら同じことなんですね
だって決まったんだから
こういうことですよと
こういうことだから こういうことだから
そうやってもう残酷に理屈で決めつけたりする
例えば この患者さんががんですよと
がんだったらもう摘出するしかないんだと
いい ちょっと考えて 考えることはない
がんでしょ じゃあ手術して取って出す
取り出す それは決まりと
そうすると理屈ばっかりでしょうに
あるいは逆に その患者さんが女性で結構美人だとする
やっぱりすごい美人だから
やっぱりもったいないな
なんて言いますか メスを入れて傷跡それやっぱりダメですね
やっぱり可愛いんだからと
感情で やっぱりこんな可愛い美人なのにね
やめましょうよ もう傷跡ついちゃったらかっこ悪いんですよ
どちらが正しいんですかね
あなたの心臓にではなくて
肺にもう両肺にももうがんが入ってるんだ
じゃあ取りましょう がんが綺麗に周りの筋肉全部丸ごと取った方ががん細胞が消えちゃうんだとという理屈が成り立つか
やっぱりこんな美人だからね
これちょっと申し訳もったいない
だからメス 入れてはいけませんという感情の方
どちらにしたって答えが間違ってるでしょ
判断は間違っている ですから
論理型も良くないし 感情も良くない
いわゆる脳の左も使う
使う方法 我々の使い方は良くないし
右の方も使い方は良くないんですよ
どちらでも我々には結局苦しみしか作ってない
音楽家も芸術家も美術もやっている人々も
みんなもう地獄の苦しみを味わっているし
そこで科学的な研究ばっかりやっている人々もものすごい苦しんでいて
ろくな結果は人類にやってないんですよ
それで仏教的な立場というのはすごい違う立場なんですね
例えば人を殺してはいけないと言っているんですね
それは単なる命令じゃないんです
すごい論理的なんです
なぜかというと 厳密な論理で考えると
私は相手を殺す それ正しければ相手が私を殺す
それも正しいでしょ すごい厳密な論理で考えてください
私は人を殺す それは正しい
いいんですよ 決めたら
だったら相手が私を殺す
それは正しいでしょう
そうすると 誰が誰が殺してもいいんです
論理的に誰が誰を殺したっても
別にどうったことない
それ純粋論理なんですね
そうすると そこでそこで止まらないで
もう感覚的に感情的にはどうですかと
まあ私が嫌だから こいつは嫌だから
やっぱり殺したいんだと
だから人を私が人を殺す
それは嫌だからいいんだと
決めるならば 人が私を殺すと
それはいいことだ いい
自分が死にたくないと
自分が殺されてほしくないという感情があるでしょうに
そこで論理的にだけじゃなくて
感情的に計算してみると
私を殺されて 私は殺されてほしくないということがあるんですね
で それまた論理的に持っていくんですよ
私を殺されてほしくないということは
相手も相手を殺されてほしくないということでしょうに
だから殺されてほしくないのに殺すということは
相手の気持ちを無視したことになる
だから相手の気持ちを無視することは
相手のいわゆる権利 人権ですか
それを無視することにもなる
じゃあ自分の方に見てもらえば
自分の気持ちを無視することは一番嫌なんですね
私の気持ちを理解してくれ
私の気持ちもわかってくれという願いだから
それで理屈の論理的な部分と人間の感覚的な部分を混ぜて考えちゃうと
結論は殺してはならないということになるんです
殺してはならないと それで次に
それは人間だけですかと
調べてみると どんな生命もやっぱり自分の命を可愛いと思っている
だから自分の命を可愛いと思っているのに
その生命を殺すことは
その生命の人権を奪うこと
になるんですね だから殺すなかれというならば
いかなる生命も殺してはならんと
それではっきりした法律的な文句が出来上がっちゃうんです
それはもう変えることはできません
誰にもできません この人間の中でいい加減自分の好き勝手にだって殺さなきゃ生きていけませんと何か屁理屈言いますけど
正しく論理的にやるとこれは変えられません
例えば やっぱり人間が手紙なんか来る場合
読んでみると 人間は魚を食べているのではないかと
だから魚ぐらい殺してもいいんじゃないかという人もいる
理屈はどこにあるんですかね
ああいう屁理屈出てくるんですよ
普通の人間の中で だから私に質問がいくつか来たんだけど
やっぱり生きる上ではやっぱり魚ぐらいでも食べなく食べているのではないかと
ですから 魚取ってる漁師たちが魚取ってるでしょう
だからその摂取はいいんじゃないんでしょうか
そこでどんな理屈ですかね
皆様にわかりますかね
私もあまりこの答えません
その時はちょっと避けますよ
なぜかというと すごいものすごい大胆な答えを出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからなぜ魚は殺すべきかと
その人を決めるのは私が食べるんだからなんですよ
私の餌ですよということは
殺す理屈になるんですかね
だったらライオンに私を殺す権利は十分あります
もし私が今日から人間の肉食べるようにする
そうすると私に人を殺す権利が成り立つでしょ
人間の体に一番いい人間の肉なんですよ
だって魚っていうのは泥ばっかし
食ってないものばっかり食べてるんだからね
肉も良くないし 鶏やらね
豚やらどんな汚いものばっかり食べて食べてはいけませんよ
体に悪いんです すごい上等なものを食べている人間の肉は
まあほとんど人間の体に必要な材料は全部揃ってるんだから
だから一番体にぴったし合う最高なものを食べたければ
人間の肉を食べるしか方法ないんです
それである人が じゃあ私は今日から人間の肉食べると決めちゃったら
その人に人を殺す権利が成り立つでしょうに
だって私は人間の肉を食べてるんだから殺してるんだと
だってあなたは魚食べてるんだから魚殺してるでしょと
そういうのは屁理屈とわかりません
そうすると だから人間が魚食べてるんだから
魚ぐらい殺してもいいんじゃないんですか？というのは何にも成り立たない論理なんです
だからこの論理も論理で
この本当に仏教以外では論理できないと思いますけど
だから私も本当に遠慮して遠慮して
あまり論理的には言ってないんです
論理的に言うと こんな本当にとんでもないんですよ
ものすごいガタガタと
この作っている世界っていうのは壊れて壊れていくんですよ
だから逆に皆様方は仏教を勉強して
もっと元気になって この弱いこの我々
失礼な言葉なんですけど
もういつでも腰抜け性格でしょ
まあもう腰低いというよりは腰抜けなんですけど
腰が引くのはいいんだけど
まああっちにペコペコ
こっちにペコペコ ああそうですか
そうですかとか そうじゃなくて
もう堂々と生きていられるんですよ
お釈迦様の教えを理解すれば
だから自分の生き方 自分の足場はしっかりするんです
だから自分の自分の島を自分でしょうし
仏教ではね 本当にすごい厳密に論理だったら厳密に論理使うんだけど
やっぱり人間作っている理屈とは違うんで
それでも人間の理屈はいつでもおかしいんだから
例えば平和はいいんですよと言いながら戦争を正当化する
戦争の場合は 例えばイラクとどこでしたっけ？えっと
クウェート で イラクはクウェートを侵略したでしょ
そこでアメリカが入って入り込んじゃって
もう もういっぱい爆弾を落としても負けちゃったんですね
そこで負けたんだから
全部お金払わなくちゃいけないんですね
だからそこで論理はどこですかと
例えば日本は戦争で負けたでしょうに
で 負けたんだだから日本は全部このお金を払わなくちゃいけないんですね
それで もし日本が勝ったならば
第2次世界戦争で で 負けた人々はみんなお金を払わなくちゃいけないと
あれ？あれは理屈ですかね
だからそちらの理屈は
勝った人の勝ち 勝った人は正しいという理屈でしょうに
ヘリクツだとおわかりでしょう
戦争の原理は 戦争の理は
勝った人は正当派で 負けた人は間違ってるっていうことでしょうに
そこで戦争の手段から見れば
凶暴であれば凶暴のほど
残酷であれば残酷なほど勝ちやすいでしょうに
すべて道徳もなんだかんで無視して
原爆弾でも何でもばらまいたりとかね
劣化ウランでも何でもいいんだからって言って撃ちまくっちゃうと
イラクでやったような感じで
爆弾を雨のように降って降らせてやるぞと
で やっちゃうと 凶暴であれば凶暴のほど勝つでしょうに
ですから 凶暴な人 残酷な人
殺戮の意識が強い人が正しいということになるでしょうに
そういう論理であって
もう負けた人は大量殺戮にしたことはとんでもないことやと
また裁判で裁くと 僕らから見ればもうむちゃくちゃなんですよ
この理屈じゃないんですよ
むちゃくちゃなんですよ
例えば 国同士で戦ったならば
両方間違ってるでしょうに
仏教から見れば なんで殺し合うんですかね
だから もし国二つ戦った戦争をしたならば
両方間違っちゃって 両方とも賠償金払わなくちゃいけないんですよ
勝っても負けても関係ないんだと
全部払えと 誰に払うんですかというと
それとんでもないことで
いろいろ政府やらみんな余計な盗んじゃうんですね
そのお金を それで戦争で誰が一番困ったかと
一般国民でしょうに いつでも平和で生きている人がやられるんですよ
誰にも悪いことをしないで
自分で自分の畑を耕して
もう子供にご飯を作ってあげて
普通に生活している人はみんな苦しんじゃうでしょうに
今もあちこち戦争あるでしょうに
それで難民になって あっち逃げるわ
こっち逃げるわ もう病気になるわ
途中で子供たちが死んでしまうわ
戦いたくない ただ平和で暮らしたいと思う人々が一番悲しい思いするでしょうに
だから そういう人々に損害賠償を両側から払わなくちゃあかんですが
論理的に考えちゃうとそういう世界じゃないでしょうに
だから世の中の理屈は私は全然認めません
まるっきり理屈はないんだと
論理はないんだと ヘリクツだ
だから論理あるのはお釈迦様の教えだけなんですよ
それはもうしょうがないんです
きつい言い方かもしれませんが
それはそんなこと言ってはいけないんですよ
我々は仏教だけ正しいとかなんとかとかはね
それを皆様が決めるんだって
これは探検して本当かないか調べることなんですけど
一応まあ自分の個人的な判断で言えば
それぐらい厳密に正しい論理性は
お釈迦様しか語ってないことは確かなんです
だから 例えば仏教の立場から言えば
なんで人が戦争をするか
なぜ戦うかと 一つは自分が正しいと
自分が正しいと誰が決めるんですかね
相手が間違っていると
そういう気持ちでしょ
それで戦争が起こるんですよ
それは一つのわけ それ自体ヘリクツでしょ
自分が正しいかないかということは
もうすごい智慧のある第三者が決めなくちゃいけないんですよ
もし私は言うなら私が正しいと
それでこのいえ あんたは間違って私は正しいと
それで私はお互いに殺し合いやるんじゃなくて
智慧のある第三者のところに行って調べてくださいと
私はこういう言い分です
それでこの方はこういう言い分です
どちらの言い分は理にかなっているかというふうに第三者が決めるべきものであって
戦争の場合 そうじゃないでしょうに
私が正しい 相手が間違っている
だから殺してやると それでどんな理屈ですかね
あるの たとえ間違っても
なぜ戦争する必要あるんですかね
それは一つ もう一つは
自分が強い 死ぬわけはないんだと
という気持ち それを全部経典のいろんなところにあるものを
私は日本語で言ってるんですけどね
自分が強くて死ぬわけじゃないんだと思うんだと
それも非論理的でしょ
人間は強いわけじゃないんです
知らないわけでもないんです
なのに 私にはこれぐらい財産があって
これぐらい武器があって
これぐらい大きな国があって
これぐらいの強い軍隊があるんだから
負けるわけにはいきませんと
負けませんと と思うこと自体
あまりにも非論理的なんですね
それでいてドーンと戦っちゃう
その 2番目の理由は日本にあったでしょうに
日本は負けるはずがないんだと平気で一般国民に嘘を言って言って言って
大量に人を殺しちゃったんですね
だから最初からもうやっぱりこれやばいと
死ぬかもしれない 死ぬんだと
こんな戦いに行ったら思ったら戦争は起こりません
ですから 人間は論理的だったら
私たちは弱いんだと ちょっとしたことで死ぬんだと
だから戦いやめましょうということになるんですよ
でもそう思わないで 屁理屈で思う
いえ すごく強いんだと
大国だと なんだ こんな小さな国々なんかすぐ簡単に潰せるんだと
そういうふうに思っちゃうと戦争が起こるんですよ
例えば北朝鮮の場合は
このテレビで見る情報だけなんですけど
いつでも国民に暗示かけてるんですね
偉大なる何々さんが我々の救済主だ
我々をもう救ってくれるんだ
こんなに偉大で もう神様にしてあげてると
金日成とか何とかという化け物を
ただの化け物なんですけど
ものすごい神様に仕立てられて
で もうすべての情報番組も
歌やら賛美歌やら何だかんでも作って
もう幼稚園の子供にまで教えられて
歌わせて踊らさせて いろんなことをして
で 完璧に屁理屈でしょ
全くも科学性も論理性もないでしょうに
それで子供たち そうやってマインドコントロールされたところで強いだと勘違いする
食べ物もないのに 飢えているのに
金正恩からすべて頭がおかしくなっていて
テポドンとかなんとかっていうミサイルを作ろうとする
そんなお金あるならば
もう苦しんでいる人々に米ぐらいあげればいいでしょうに
だからこの世の中で理屈
論理はないんですよ 論理があるんだったら
もうそれはすごい素晴らしいことなんです
で まあ論理的にはまあそこら辺で話を終わりますけど
今日もう一つこう 忘れちゃったんだ
直感っていうのを どうしますか？あと十五分ぐらいしゃべりますとか
まあ直感は十五分ではありませんですけどね
まあまあ ちょっと私にとってはこのタイトルはもうあまりにも大胆すぎですよ
ちょっと扱いにくいんです
あの なぜならば 私もすごく気をつけて
気をつけて これでも気をつけて喋ってるんですよ
失礼なことを全く言わないで
で ですから あの 本当に論理って何なのかというと
やっぱり遠慮はできなくなっちゃうんです
バンバンと言わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
論理だからね 論理っていうのはバンバンと言うことだからね
だから それで直感というものは何なのかって
皆様それ説明だけします
あの 皆様方が思っている直感がありますね
で 仏教ではあの論理と直感
両方認めるんですよ 両方必要ですよ
今 論理のことはもういくらかわかるでしょうと思いますけどね
いくらかですよ ものすごい
もう今日はたくさん言いたいことがありまして
もう全部忘れちゃった
あの どのように論理作るか
論理構成をどうしますか？とかね
何が論理で何が論理でないかとかね
もうたくさんあります
で 直感って何なのかと
そこであの あの これだけ覚えておいてください
一般的に我々が言ってる直感は
あれダメですよ あの直感はやめた方がいいんです
普通の我々 日常生活で使うでしょ
私の直感でわかったんですよとか何とかとかね
あの直感は一番危険 だから自分が思ったことは後でぴったし合いましたかないかということは問題ではありません
この日本語で このこれは日本語の問題です
あの普通のあの日本語で
まあ直感という意味は
その意味で今説明しています
その場合 直感というのはあまり情報があったわけじゃないんですよ
証拠があったわけでもないんです
ただ なんとなく自分の気持ちでそう思ったんです
直感で だから あの試験なんかはね
あの選択でしょう あの 5つが 1 2
3 4  4 5ぐらいあってね
1つ選ぶことだから もう勉強する必要ないんですよ
直感で全部もうバスをバスですか
もうバツ印を書いてくればいいんだから
だからそういう それはもういい加減なんですよ
その直感というのは変なんです
ほとんどそれ直感と言わない
仏教は とにかくそれはもうとっくにご存知だと思いますけど
私は違うことを言いたいんですね
あの あの 時々あの それは女の勘ですよとかね
よく言う場合もあるし
で  女にだけじゃなくて
男の人もそうやって直感でアホなことはよくやりますけど
で 競馬とかね やってるでしょうに
一つも当たらないでしょうに
まあどちらも同じなんですけど
あの あまり理屈使わない
あまり情報を取って対照して調べようとしないで
じゃあこれにしますというふうな感じの心の働きなんですね
今 直感というのは でも本当に仏教で直感というのは直と感なんです
間がないという意味なんです
文字通りの直感なんです
それは 100%合ってるんです
論理の場合は間があるんです
結論まで いわゆる情報があって
この情報の段取りを得て真理に至ると
直感というのは間がなく
もう結論と じゃあそれをちょっとした例でわかりやすく説明します
はい えーと この部屋は涼しいんですね
なぜ涼しいですかね この部屋は涼しいでしょうし
なぜ涼しいですか？これはもう簡単に
まあまあ そんなに厳密に言わなくてもいいんでしょうし
あの まあただ冷房がついてるんだからなんです
冷房ついてるんだから涼しいんです
もうわかりやすいことで間違いますかね
それは この部屋に冷房がついてます
だから涼しいですよというのは言うまでもないこと
当たり前のこと それは百パーセント合っている
合っている これは例ですよ
もっと厳しいんですけど
直感というのは そこで冷房はついている
それなのに暑くて汗がタラタラで状態でいると
その時どうします？この部屋に冷房がついているし
フル回転しているし それでもなかなかもう暑くて汗がタラタラもう垂らしながらも座っていられない状態
その場合は我々は論理を使うんです
真理を知るために それで論理を使うんです
あれ なんでしょうね 冷房はついてるんだけど
もしかするとスイッチの入れ間違いではないかと
冷房ではなくて暖房になってるんではないかとかね
暖房になってない冷房の機能です
あるいは空気が詰まってるんではないかと
そうやって論理に行くんですよ
そこでまあ空気も詰まってるわけじゃないと
であるならば なんで暖かいんですかと
それ探してみると あ こういうことだと原因見つかるんですね
何かの原因 まあ例えば窓からずっともう直射して
もう太陽の日光を入ってるんだと
すると あ おそらくこの冷房でいくら空気を空気を冷やしても
太陽の方がより暑くて暖めているんだと
だからなかなか涼しくならないんだよというふうに結論に至る
それは間違ってるんじゃないんですよ
間違ってるんじゃない
正しい結論に至りました
真理を発見しました でも過程があったんですよ
直感の場合は何のことない
あ 涼しいな 冷房ついてるんだから
それで終わり だから理屈は入らないんです
だから直感っていうのは
この論理過程入らないで
瞬時に真理に至る で ですから直感っていうのは楽なんですよ
考えなくてもいいんだから
でも日常生活でいう直感とは違うんです
日常生活で我々普通に言ってる
もうあなたの直感ですねとか
皆さん あんなものは当てにならない
もういい加減で全然当てにならない
全く捨てた方がいい 直感に頼らない方がいい
ろくなものにならない
でも仏教でいう直感というのはそうじゃなくて
パッと百パーセント正しい真理に
結論に 答えに至る その百パーセント正しい答えに段取りを得て至るんだったら
論理で段取りなしにパッといったならば直感で
だからもうちょっといろんな例で考えましょう
で 私は立っていたんだから疲れたと
で 座る 座ったらあ 楽になったと
あ 座ったんだから楽になった
で このすぐわかること
間違いなくわかること
ですから この瞑想では
このここら辺は訓練させるんですよ
人間が百パーセントのもう絶対変わらぬ真理にあってほしいんですよ
推測はもう意味がないんですよ
だから我々の脳の能力をさらに育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから 論理過程で 論理過程で
論理過程 やっと真理見つかったんだと言ったっても意味がないんです
なぜ意味がないかというと
はっきり実感がないんですよ
この論理過程で真理に至っても
例えばこの私は我々説法で
この全てのものはドッカであると
無常であると 実体はないと
徹底的に論理的に説明していくんでしょうに
いくら徹底的に論理的に説明しても
皆様方納得いっても何か欠けているんですよ
実感がないんです だから論理過程で真理に至っても納得はいく
それしかないんだと でも実感がない
だから実感っていうのは直感で出てくるんです
だから直感っていうのは
例えば私は皆様に じゃあ口を開けてください
飴入れますから といって何か口に入れちゃう
入れて飴だと思って舐めてみると
これでまあ嫌な味で ものすごい苦いと
それ そうすると その味わった人がものすごく嫌な顔をするでしょうね
あまりにも苦くて 日本で本当に苦いものはないんですね
例を出したいんだけどね
自分の国だったらもう死ぬほど苦いものはありますよ
なんか日本にありますわ
ものすごい苦い何か え？え？そういうものは私は知らないんですけどね
日本の植物関係ではそれほどないと思いますけどね
あの その地球の位置によってね
植物の味が変わりますからね
南の方に行くと はっきりと味が変わっている
もう区別明確にするようになっちゃいますからね
で あの ある植物があります
あれは薬なんですけど
舐めてちょっとでももう試しで遊びで舐めてみたら
まあ 1週間苦いというぐらい苦いんですよ
一回その苦みを感じたら
あの香りが来る時でも
もうもう苦いという気持ちがわかるほど
でも悪いことにものすごく体にいい薬なんです
だからもうそういう何か病気になったら
もう否が応なしに飲まなくちゃいけないことにもなりますけど
そういう植物もあります
とにかく飴だと思って
私はそうやって何か苦いものを口に入れて入れたり
入れてあげたりする そうすると本人が前で前もってこれは飴でしょう
ですから甘いでしょう
だから美味しいでしょうという先入観がいっぱいもある
先入観もいっぱいあるのにも関わらず
口に舐めてみたところで
まあ嫌で苦くて それで私は聞く
美味しいでしょ？どう答えますか？もう殴られるかもしれませんし
美味しいところではなくてね
それで私はその人に説得させようとする
あなたはそんな苦いと思っても
これは甘いんですよ 美味しいんですよと
だから私言うことを信じなさいよ
言っても信じないでしょうに
あなたの言うことを信じません
私の口に入ったものはとんでもない味でしたと
それは直感ですよ 直感だから誰が聞いても聞かない
誰にも説得することはできません
いくら先入観があっても
もう直感ではせむなくなっちゃうんです
直感というのはそういうことで
すごい強烈で事実なんです
ですから 無常っていうのは直感で見てくださいということなんです
そうすると お釈迦様は信じる必要ないんです
そういうことだから この瞑想を通して
この直感の仕方が育てるんですよ
だから我々ヴィパッサナー瞑想で痛みを感じたら
余計なことを考えないで痛みとちゃんと確認してみなさい
と なんで痛いだろうと思ったら
もうもう追い出すんです
まあ追い出すとはすいませんだけど
気持ちとしては出ていけという気持ちなんです
あなたは無理やと 頭は育てません
例えば座って座禅組んでもうヴィパッサナー瞑想していると
まあ足が痛くて痛くてたまらなかったんだと
だから痛みと確認してくださいと
いや まあ確認はしたんだけど
なかなか消えませんねとかね
それだったら僕 お釈迦様は思っている智慧が出てこないんですよ
なぜかというと もう固定概念で消えるだろうと希望があって
で 理屈が使ったりして
で ヴィパッサナーで何を育てるかで
この直感を育てるんですよ
で 痛みは痛みで確認する
しびれだと思ったら これ痺れとして確認する
なんで痺れるんだろうかと思ったら理屈でしょ
そうすると痺れる原因は 1 1 1 1 仮定を経て調べなくちゃあかんでしょうね
それは揺らぎ それは揺れる智慧なんです
揺らぎない智慧ではないんです
だから痛みで止まったら
それは揺らぎない経験なんですね
そうやって この論理的な
いわゆる過程を経てから得る智慧と過程を踏まないで直接得る智慧という 2つ分けてあって
仏教は悟りとして認めるのはこの直感の智慧なんです
それはもう揺らぎません
誰が何と言おうとも もうどうにもならない
それ体験しちゃったらもう
もう事実を自分で発見したんだから
だからそこら辺まで仏教の心の働き
すごい厳密にしているんです
無常だろうというのはダメですよ
せっかくお釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだから
やっぱり無常でしょう
何の役にも立たない  せっかく偉大なるお釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだからね
まあまあ やっぱり人生は苦しみでしょうね
それは何の意味もないんです
そういうのはまあ論理的に過程であって
直感というのはもう自分で舐めてみたことと同じなんです
で それで論理構成悪いと
あの 思う これ説明するちょっとした物語が
その仏教的じゃない その物語で話を終了します
一回もこの同じことを言ったんです
あの このある若者が大量にヨーグルトを作って
たくさん 昔話で あのヨーグルトっていうのは簡単に作れますからね
牛乳をもうちょっと温めて
あの 固める何かヨーグルトの種ですけど
前のヨーグルトちょっと入れちゃったらもう固まります
固まりますからね ヨーグルトを作って
これ売りに行くんです
おいしいヨーグルトですよ
おいしいヨーグルトいかがでしょうか？と売りに行ったら
そこら辺でこの生まれつき目が見えない人がいたんですね
いたら その人はヨーグルトを見たことがないんです
ここで聞くんですよ 君
このヨーグルトって何でしょうかと
これはすごい もう美味しいものですよ
ったら まあというならば買いたいんだけど
買う前に調べたいんですけど
どのようなものですか？と
言ったら そう言われても
これはすごい真っ白いんだ
ヨーグルト 真っ白いと言ってもわかりませんだから真っ白いってどんなものかと
真っ白いっていうのは
この鶴のように 鶴のような色ですよと
鶴のような色ですっても目が見えないでしょうに
わからないんですよ あんた鶴知らないんですか？と
鶴っていうのはこんな形の鳥ですよと
手で鶴の形をして見せたんです
そこで目が見えない人はこうやって触ってみて
あ なるほど こんな形のものか
じゃあヨーグルト要りませんと
じゃあ決めました ヨーグルト要りませんと
こんなものは要りませんだから
ですから このあの仮定をして考えちゃうと
そういう問題になるんです
だから目が見えない人でも
あの まあ白いとかね もう認識次元に関係ないものを言わないで
これは食べたら美味しいですよと
舐めたら美味しいですと言ったら
その目が見えない人はもう幸せになるはずでしたけどね
ですから この人間にわからないものをね
言ったっても無意味なんですよ
だから目が見えない人にヨーグルトは鶴のようなものだと言ったところで
とんでもない結論に至ってしまったんだから
ですから この我々生きている世界で
まあ宗教であろうが何であろうか
もう人間にもわけもわからない
科学では説明できないものはいくらいっぱいありますよと言っていい加減なことを言う
こんな幽霊現象は それは科学では説明できませんと
でも私も大槻教授の立場でいい加減なことを言うなよと
科学で説明できない 人間の知識範囲で説明できないんだったら放っておけと
そんなものは 言ってることは嘘でしょうと
科学でも説明できないものは
どうやって科学知識 能力何もない馬鹿者に説明できるんですかね
たとえ 例えば写真撮ったところで
そこで幽霊が写ってやったんだと
それは科学者に説明できないんだと
だったら どこかにいるね
くだらない人に説明できますかね？やっぱりこれは幽霊です
これはもう亡くなったおばあさんがあなたの前にうらあって恨んでるんですよと平気で言うでしょうね
あんた気をつけなさいよと
事故を起こすかもしれませんと
だからそうやって人間をこの騙されるんですよ
簡単に だからもう世の中の科学を信じた方がより簡単でしょうしね
科学者に聞いてみれば
この写真はどんな写真かと
それでもう光の光学とかいろいろあるでしょうね
いろいろ見て まあまあ
こういうことではないかと説明してくれると思いますし
だから科学で説明できないものだからと事実というわけでもないし
もう何でも科学で科学で説明できるわけでもないんでしょうし
まあとにかくこの人間の認識に入らないものを言っても無意味ですということだけ言いたいんですけど
まあとにかくそういうことで
論理は大変大事なもので
思慮を理解するために
それからはっきりした変わらぬ心理をするために
直感というものは使う必要があります
ですから このまあちょっと左と右いじっただけではできません
ちゃんとこのもう一つの脳の機能を育てなくちゃいけないんですから
それは瞑想を通して教えているので
どうもありがとうございます
はい